Speaker 1: Oh, speaking of it, looking very
ugly. You're not going to believe this. Donald
Trump was convinced that China had a hurricane
gun that they were using to shoot hurricanes at
the United States. Let that sink in. Trump thought
China had a hurricane gun Rolling Stone article.
Trump kept asking if China was
shooting us with a hurricane gun.
The then leader of the free world also inquired
whether the U.S. could bomb China in retaliation
for the alleged hurricane attack. So he wanted
to bomb Mexico. And he also wanted to bomb China.
Look at this. Near the beginning of Trump's time
in office, the then president had a pressing
question for his national security aides and
administration officials. Does China have the
secret technology a weapon even to create large
manmade hurricanes and launch them at the United
States? And if so, would this be an act of war
by a foreign power? And if so, could the U.S.
retaliate militarily? Trump repeatedly asked about
it, according to two former senior administration
officials and a third person briefed on the
matter. A former Trump official recently said,
quote, It was almost too stupid for words. I
did not get the sense he was joking at all.
Wow. The sources tell Rolling Stone that Trump
started interrogating national security officials
and other staffers about the alleged weapon during
the first year of his presidency. And it would
pop up sporadically, at least until the end of
2018. Two of the sources recalled that as Trump
got deeper into the second year, he started to
drop the topic but would sometimes joke about it.
The other former senior official said. I
was present once when he asked if China made
hurricanes to send to us. He wanted to know if the
technology existed. One guy in the room responded,
Not to the best of my knowledge, sir. I kept it
together until I got back to my office. I did
not know where the then president would have heard
about it. He was asking about it around the time,
maybe a little before he asked people about
nuking hurricanes. Now, I have to tell you.
If you believe China has a hurricane gun. It's
more logical that you would ask, Can we nuke a
hurricane like it once was? You know how sometimes
things don't. Things don't make any sense, but
they have, like an internal logic. So, like, I'll
give you an example. This this is a real example.
And you might say, David, this is nothing like it.
But okay, if you believe abortion is murder, okay,
it would follow from that that you might say
prosecute women who have abortions for murder.
Okay. I disagree with all of it. I disagree
abortion. I disagree with any of it 100% against
it. Against all of it. But I understand if you
believed abortion was murder, you might believe
all these other things and try to do all these
other things. Okay. A little bit like that. If
you believed China had a hurricane gun where
they could shoot hurricanes at the country.
It wouldn't be as crazy to be like, could we
nuke a hurricane? I don't know. Is that almost
too charitable to Trump? I'm not really sure. But
this is, you know, does the flu vaccine work for
COVID? Was one of the things Trump asked early
in the pandemic. What about injecting bleach?
You might remember Marjorie Taylor GREENE. Jewish
space lasers. You might remember when Congressman
Louie Gohmert asked the National Park Service
if they could maybe alter the orbit of the moon
in order to ease climate change. Okay, this is up
there with that. Does China have a hurricane gun?
And the theme here. There's really two themes.
One theme is Trump constantly confused and
ignorant about just about everything. That's
that's one thing. And then the second theme,
Trump really wanting to know about bombing all
sorts of people. Remember, early, it was either
late in the campaign or early in the presidency.
Trump had to be told why we can't really
have nuking Europe on the table. Like there's
all these geopolitical reasons why you can't.
We can't nuke Europe. It's just not something
that you can do. He wanted to bomb Mexico and
Mark Esper had to kind of talk him, dissuade him
from doing that in order to go after the cartels.
He was asking about nuking hurricanes as
well as retaliating militarily against
China for what he suspected might be some kind
of hurricane gun in order to shoot a hurricane.
The theme is bombing, bombing, bombing. And it is
absolutely and completely nuts. We will have more
on this on the David Pakman Show Instagram
page, which you can find at David Pakman
show. We're going to take a quick break. We've
got great stuff coming up on the show today.